-Now, look, we love
our audience.
You watch us every night.
But right now, we want to change
things up and watch you.
We asked you guys at home
to send us some fun or unique
talents that you have.
Quest, get ready,
these are good.
We got submissions
from thousands of people
all across the world, and we're
going to meet some of them now.
It's time for
"Show Me Something Good."
-♪ Show me something good,
show me something good ♪
♪ Show me something good,
won't you just show me ♪
-Alright, let's meet
our first guest.
Hello.
Hi!
-Hello!
-What is your name,
and where are you from?
-My name is Leigh, and
I'm from Princeton, New Jersey.
-Hey, New Jersey! Leigh!
Yeah, come on, Leigh.
I see you have props.
What talent
will you be showing us?
-I am going to be
balancing a book on my head,
playing the melodica --
This is my glorified
melodica stand --
I mean lovely roommate Ana.
-Hey, Ana. How are you?
Nice to see you.
-I will also be spinning a piece
of color guard equipment.
-Oh, wow. This is unbelievable.
What a talent.
How did you --
How did you figure out
that you could do this?
-Oh, it was just sheer luck.
I knew I could do each
of these things individually
and then figured, "Eh, let's see
if I can put them all together."
-Here we go. I think it's going
to be a show-stopper.
Whenever you're ready,
go for it.
-Alright. Here we go.
-Alright, the book.
That's one talent there.
Uh-huh. Wow.
-Whoa.
[ Melodica playing ]
♪♪
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh!
Oh, fantastic!
♪♪
Leigh, thank you very much!
Oh, my God. Ana!
Your assistant, Ana,
thank you very much.
Very talented.
That's fantastic.
Thank you.
Let's meet our next guest here.
Hey, bud.
-Hello.
-How are you, pal?
What is your name,
and where you from?
-I'm Sam, and I'm from
Georgetown, Kentucky.
-Hey, welcome to the show, Sam.
Sam, looks like
you need some artwork there.
[ Laughter ]
Anything. Uh...
You're not in a prison
somewhere, are you, Sam?
Are you okay?
-No, I took it all off the wall,
'cause it's a bit busy.
-Oh, I appreciate it, buddy.
What is the talent that you'll
be showing us tonight, bud?
-I can do a noise
that sounds like the wheel
from "The Wheel of Fortune."
[ Laughter ]
-Sam?
Sam, you're sitting in front
of like three guitars.
I'm just saying.
You took the posters
off the wall.
You have musical instruments.
What is your talent again?
You're making the sound
of the what?
-[ Laughing ] The wheel
from "The Wheel of Fortune."
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Well, I think we can maybe
help you out with this.
Audience, can you help him out?
On the count of three,
we'll say, "Wheel of Fortune,"
then Sam will do his thing.
You ready? 1, 2, 3.
[ Drum roll ]
-Wheel of Fortune!
[ Breath clicking rapidly ]
[ Clicking slowing ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Sam, that was amazing!
That's what I'm talking about.
That's good TV right there.
How in the heck
did you know to do that?
I love it.
Let's meet our final guest here.
Hello! Hi. What's your name,
and where you from?
-Hi. I'm Kyra Gallego, and I'm
from Los Angeles, California.
-Welcome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome to our show.
What talent will you be
sharing with us tonight?
-Well, I'm not a ventriloquist,
but I can talk
with my mouth closed.
-Mm. Alright,
I'm intrigued, Kyra.
Let's -- Show me
whenever you're ready.
Yeah. Show me what you can do.
-Okay. [ Clears throat ]
[ Muffled ]
Jimmy! Help me! It's Justin!
Can you hear me?
♪♪
-I couldn't hear you. I think --
Did you say, "It's me.
It's Kyra. Can you hear me?"
Is that what you said?
-Justin Timberlake.
He's calling for you.
-I was like,
"It's Dustin from my libido."
That's what I heard.
-No.
-But it's still amazing.
How do you do that?
-Well, I'm a teacher,
so I got to get kids
to pay attention somehow.
So I'll be like,
"Hey, pay attention!"
[ Both laugh ]
And they just -- "Whoa."
-"Hey, pay --"
Yeah, like, what is going on?
Well, I was thinking,
this could be kind of fun.
Could we bring everyone else
back on the screen?
Could you guys maybe play us out
with a song
if you guys
combine your talents?
-Oh, sure. We got a beautiful
little ballad for you.
[ Melodica playing ]
-[ Muffled vocalizing ]
♪♪
[ Breath clicking ]
[ Melodica,
vocalization continue ]
♪♪
We'll be right back with more
"Tonight Show," everybody.
Come on back.
I thought you forgot about Sam!
I thought they forgot about Sam.
Oh, my gosh.